we're joined now from New York by Alina
Haber a lawyer for president Trump good
evening good to have you with our son on
what is an incredible day for uh Donald
Trump and of course for you U.S politics
and history
I understand you are with the president
uh this week at some point I'm not sure
if you were with him when he found out
about the indictment but tell us about
his reaction to it
um his reaction is
um not surprisingly resilient and strong
he has been obviously hearing the rumors
as all of Americans have that this Witch
Hunt as he calls it would be coming to
fruition
um we had hoped that that wouldn't be
the case unfortunately you know we
learned because the D.A is not
communicating or being transparent as
they normally would through the Press so
when we understood that there was an
indictment um he took it he I think was
disappointed in the state of our country
as he has been for the past couple years
frankly and and uh this is just another
example of how we need to take back the
White House
what was your reaction to the indictment
were you shocked
yes I was shocked I think
I'm not sure maybe not shocked I was
um you know it was another here we go
again uh this has been his life since
2016 when he went down the escalator you
have to remember they did this with the
Russia hoax they tried to take his kids
down they did this with his first
impeachment his second impeachment and
now we have a D.A who has decided to
bring what to me is the weakest and
oldest uh it's not even a crime I'm not
even sure what it is it's it's barely a
misdemeanor he is somebody who in the
state of New York has said that he
doesn't believe in putting people in
jail and he believes in changing the
federal crimes to misdemeanors but for
Donald Trump has reversed it he's you
know his pack was was gassed up by
George Soros you describe it as barely a
misdemeanor then are you saying that as
far as you understand what he's being
accused of he did actually do it
no it's a misdemeanor to do a book and
record keeping violation that is what
we're understanding this to be we still
haven't seen the indictment
um and the way this went as everybody
knows is what Michael Cohen testified to
what his lawyers have said which is that
he initiated a payment to somebody who
was effectively trying to extort him and
all I can say to you is this I'm a
lawyer and I represent a lot of people
and if people sign ndas and get paid for
it or as an attorney I pay people who
try and extort someone because they just
don't want to deal with it and then
those clients are somehow going to get
indicted publicly let alone a former
president that is a very sad State of
Affairs and very politically motivated
Michael Cohen's lawyer Lanny Davis was
on with me earlier Alina and he says
that there is no allegation it is very
firm and established by prosecutors in
the previous case where Michael Cohen
was went to jail that Donald Trump
directed him to make this payment
I would just direct everybody's
attention to the federal prosecutors
that already evaluated this and threw
this case out and also the FEC that
looked at it for any campaign Finance
violations and threw it out uh frankly
Bragg did it as well there is no
consequence there's no there's no
coincidence here this is a political
hack he is leading in the polls and
quite honestly they're helping him he is
up 30 points in the states
um and and the more they hit on him
frankly the bigger his base gets and the
stronger they get so I'm sorry that that
Michael Cohen's even part of this
discussion is is quite honestly pathetic
in itself he is a a very weak human
being who frankly has made a a complete
career out of just bashing somebody that
he's upset he doesn't work for anymore
well Michael Cohen was a trusted Ally of
the former president he works alongside
him he made this payment on his behaven
and went to jail for it and I I want to
pick up what you said about it being
politically motivated and I've heard
phrases like selective prosecution
throughout the day since this has come
out late last night UK time I I put that
to Michael Cohen's lawyer
um Lanny Davis about this being a
politically motivated indictment and he
says that other than Michael Cohen's a
testimony there will be a mountain of
evidence and he has seen this being
collated through conversations between
prosecutors and and Michael Cohen there
is a mountain of evidence he says there
are facts
is that what you think
I'm sorry to tell you but we know what
he's testified to right
yes but I can tell you when when you
state anything based on something out of
Michael Cohen's mouth or any facts we
have other and frankly you're misstating
something very important Michael Cohen
didn't go to jail for this he went to
jail for his own tax fraud he went to
jail for things that he did with
medallions and the taxis and he went to
jail for yes so let's be clear on that
um I I don't take very kindly to anybody
who takes his word or frankly a
prostitutes or whatever she calls
herself Stormy Daniels I know she has an
only fans page now and and you know is
taking q and A's I believe today on on
it this is the quality of witnesses that
we're dealing with here okay so you
can't lose sight of the fact that this
is his stale case that has been heard
already by the FEC and the federal
prosecutors for a federal crime that is
state level D.A is now trying to make a
federal crime so I'm looking forward to
seeing what New Revelations after almost
a decade they think they have but no
matter what it is you can't say it's not
selective prosecution when it's already
been prosecuted multiple times and
dismissed it is what it is uh Michael
Cohen to be clear pled guilty
um for arranging campaign finance
charges
um including this payment to Stormy
Daniels
and medallions I recommend you go back
he had he had several counts right
exactly but this was this right but this
was one of them right
and and I appreciate we we you don't
know what the indictment is because it's
sealed and we don't know what the exact
nature of the charge is but and we're
kind of going around in circles in that
sense but it is understand Stan there is
an understanding a tacit understanding
that these charges are related to Stormy
Daniels and therefore Michael Cohen's
testimony will be crucial and the fact
that he's already admitted to making
this payment and said that the former
president directed him that that is an
important piece of evidence and and and
they say that they have evidence to back
it
I believe there was a letter that was
released that you should read from 2018
from his attorneys
um that stated that Michael Cohen did so
on his own took out a loan and that he
was in no way involved and that is from
his other attorneys not Lanny Davis who
by the way I believe does not represent
him anymore so I would just fact check
that as well it's interesting I'm not
here to talk about Michael Cohen if you
have any other yeah
I apologize I'd like to know how he he
plans to deal with this going forwards
the same way anybody would deal with it
when somebody is bringing garbage
charges you hire attorneys and you move
one thing at a time and then you go to
trial and you win
and you said that you felt that his
supporters uh this only kind of
strengthened his support because it it
shows the narrative building up against
the president
yes look at the polls he's up 30 points
over uh DeSantis right now his poll
numbers have gone up since this whole
hook started and it will probably
continue to the country is angry I know
you're in the UK but this country is
angry
yeah I think there's a lot of confusion
here in the UK
um but tell us about how you feel the
anger might play out in the United
States
I think that everybody needs to go
through the process of watching the
trail let's get the indictment Let's Get
the facts
um again I'm not you know as I said
before I'm not going to answer questions
on things I'm going to speculate we have
to see the indictment we have to see
what the charges are and then the
attorneys that are handling this which
will be the criminal attorneys on the
team who are brilliant we'll go ahead
and take this uh head on and and go to
trial I I know that the president uh the
former president also called on his
supporters to protest this to to air
their views about this are you expecting
people to turn out on Tuesday when he
arrives at the court
you know I had court last week in
Manhattan on Leticia James's case the
Attorney General's case which I
personally am handling and I can tell
you that there was support that day uh
there was tremendous support and there
were people waiting and cheering us on
and we're not even on the D.A case so I
don't know I I would expect it you know
Donald Trump is probably one of the
single most famous people in the world
at the moment and
um you know he does tend to get a lot of
attention
Elena Haber we're gonna have to leave it
there Alina have a loyal to president
Donald Trump thanks very much indeed
thank you